we have some amazing bloomberg reporting
right now yeah it's a good reporting on
a story that continues forward again
once again it will be traders emails and
chat rooms this time of the government
bond traders it's going to kill bank
senior management sounds familiar how
about fx you remember that how about
libor i think that's still ongoing i'm
not even sure
now many consider government bonds when
auctioned to the street to be the new uh
territory for regulators and those
worried about big fines to bank carrie
geiger's done some terrific reporting on
this with bloomberg news within your
reporting do the emails into the chats
exist where 25 year olds or 32 year olds
said four stupid things that are going
to cost billions of dollars well we're
not exactly sure what the chats and
emails said but it's a possibility so if
you take the big picture of this as you
said before with libor and f fx those
cases were about conduct issues
internally in banks people talking
either internally or with other people
at other banks their peers about order
information and what that is is those
are largely unregulated industries fx
libor and now treasuries and so you're
seeing conduct in these unregulated
industries being a little bit of a
low-hanging fruit for the department of
distinction here is contained auction
process
they get a look early at the different
bids and desires of their customers are
you saying within your reporting with
dan kruger that that they're talking to
each other 20 minutes and one hour
before very possibly we're definitely
getting indications through our
reporting that there is conversation in
chat rooms uh you know prior to
the primary treasury auctions and as you
know the primary treasury auctions is
one of the largest you know financial
sales
you know daily yearly monthly
big deal this is a redux back 25 30
years to 1991 and south sullivan
brothers exactly so and then they
changed the auctions actually that's
when they instituted the dutch auctions
it presumably to fix this walk us
through the difference between what's
going on here and what we know happened
with lyborne fx those were call markets
comparatively easy to rig this is
something slightly different what is the
mechanism that we think happened here
well
actually it's less about the difference
and more about the similarities between
these issues and so what you have is
people comparing notes before sales
before sales are putting in aligning
orders comparing notes figuring out
demand and they're talking about these
in chat rooms is this between primary
dealers or within the primary dealer
both both probably both yeah i mean we
can't pay for sure but definitely
probably both and the issue there is is
that the department of justice has
viewed that type of activity previously
with fx which you know four banks plus
ubs pleaded guilty for just a month ago
and with libor which a couple banks have
pleaded guilty already paid huge fines
we have more banks coming up for that
that type of activity could be
considered cartel like behavior and so
that's the issue we're not saying here
that the banks are doing this in the
treasury markets but it's very similar
types of conduct that we've seen
previously does it involve all the
primary dealers do you know yet kerry
and have any of them responded so far
yeah i mean we did talk to several of
the primary dealers and we do have them
you know obviously um both with no
comments
and carrie we hate you
one of the issues some of the banks do
have very strict rules around this ubs
we reported does have very strict rules
in this they were part of obviously the
libor and the fx investigation so it
makes sense for them to institute these
policies am i naive to think that the
previous fines were because 4 28 year
olds said stupid things in emails
is that a safe assessment well i think
that that would be a very small sliver
of the larger picture but yes i mean the
problem is is you can't the justice
department doesn't like it when you talk
about orders before their place because
it opens the door to collusion and
collusion is when you break the sherman
act and this is not a standard
regulatory regime that they're using to
prosecute this you know in in the past
we've talked about sec enforcement what
they've been doing more recently which
you lay out in your article is this is
this is anti-trust behavior this
anti-trust regulation and that goes back
to what i said earlier it's about
conduct and it's the conversations are
the conduct that they're looking at and
that can be what's considered cartel or
anti-trust behavior okay and it almost
seems like you know some people are
criticizing this as saying it's
low-hanging fruit for the department of
justice to come after different trading
deaths on this and others are saying the
banks should know better okay kerry
geiger thank you so much without
question the read
worldwide today for global wall street
on
the treasury auction
process